Elon Musk has called the new factories
that Tesla is building in Austin Texas
and Berlin Germany gigantic money
furnaces and one of the consequences of
that vast pace of expansion is that it
isn't perhaps as efficient as some of
its car making Rivals look at this chart
it shows Revenue per employee quite a
good gauge of efficiency and although
it's overtaken Volkswagen its big German
rival over recent years it continues to
be a long way behind establishment names
such as Toyota General Motors and Ford
what's the impact of that well let's
look at this this is the gross profit
margin that tez is able to post and at
first glance it looks pretty good the
red line that's Tesla is above some of
those established names but Tesla when
it calculates its profit doesn't include
things like research and development
costs and it also owns its own
dealership so it's able to retain quite
a lot more of the profit margin than do
those Rivals the upshot of that is it
suggests the underlying lying economics
are not as compelling as Tesla investors
might have you imagine they will say
that electric vehicles have fewer moving
Parts than combustion engines and
therefore are going to be more
profitable that might be the case over
time as Tesla expands and has greater
economies of scale but the difference
between what Tesla does and the
established car makers the Legacy car
makers isn't for now that considerable
[Music]